welcome back china continues to taunt
and test the new administration
and the world sending 15 fighter jets
into taiwanese airspace
the united states state department
calling the intimidation tactic
concerning
this move coming as president xi jinping
is threatening a quote new cold war
against any nation that would stand up
to communist china
and issuing sanctions on those who have
pushed back
joining me right now is john ratcliffe
he is the former director of national
intelligence he sees
or he has seen all of the intelligence
most uh
in in fact the most intelligence than
anyone except for the sitting
president john ratcliffe it is wonderful
to see it tonight thank you so much for
joining us
before we get into china i really want
to get your take on what we just saw
one of the elements of this impeachment
would mean removing any security that
president trump
has is that right it would i tell you
the whole exercise though maria is silly
um
the the this is uh president trump has
now been subjected to two impeachments
um in neither one of them did he have
due process if you remember in the first
impeachment he was deprived of lawyers
for the first 71 of 76 days
you know fundamental premise of our
judicial system is due process it's a
fairness principle
and he was deprived of it was even worse
this time it was a two-day proceeding
there was no investigation
and no hearings and so uh so you have
that issue and then
and then secondly it's just really a
farce uh there's no constitutional basis
to move forward
with a trial um against a private
citizen which is what donald trump is
so um there are so many ways that as
your prior guests uh
pointed out is just this is purely a
political exercise at this point
certainly not helpful
to the american people it's
disrespectful to the office of the
presidency
i wish it wasn't happening director i
want to get into
china and whether or not you believe
that the biden administration will be
softer on china
the trump administration obviously was
the toughest on china in terms of
pushing back with sanctions
with prosecutions with tariffs do you
believe
joe biden will pull back
well maria you talked about some of the
things that china did just
this week i think it shows that china's
testing the obama administration they
you know um what i will say is um both
publicly
what china is saying and and privately
what the intelligence
showed us uh post-election is that
china's happy that
joe biden is president of the united
states it's what they wanted
and um uh they sense weakness um and i
don't mean that as an insult to
to president uh biden but china saw
weakness from the obama biden
administration and as you pointed out it
wasn't until the last four years of the
trump administration that someone stood
up to
a rising china with different policies
and sanctions to hold them accountable
in the world marketplace but china wants
to see if it's going to go back to
business as usual as it was under the
obama biden administration will the
biden-harris administration
be the same and so what you're seeing is
they're testing to see whether or not
the biden administration will stand up
to china and what's important maria is
your point about
the intelligence no one has seen more
intelligence in the last year
than i have and what the intelligence
tells us is that china
and china alone is our greatest national
security threat
and it's where the biden administration
should be put placing our greatest
emphasis with regard to our national
uh security policies and concerns so the
question is
will they um you know i i watched
a real haines confirmation hearing and
there was some tough rhetoric on china
which was good but rhetoric's got to
translate into action and we'll see if
that happens
that hasn't been the history with joe
biden let's hope
uh that that changes because maria this
is not a political issue this is about
national security and if the biden
administration fails
we all fail and suffer as a result of
that by not taking china seriously
and and we know that china has stated
its goals and ambitions very clearly it
wants to become the number one
superpower
overtaking the united states in that
regard not just economically
but militarily now the trump
administration has pushed back on
investors who ex helped to fund
china's expansion by banning investment
into chinese companies that are tied to
the military i want you to listen to jen
pasaki the
press uh the press person for for
president biden and what she said about
what they're doing right now
in terms of delisting delisted chinese
companies in in on the new york
exchanges as well as the potential
for investment into these companies
listen to this
there are a number of reviews complex
reviews interagency reviews i should say
that we're going to undertake
a range of regulatory actions and a
range of
relationships with companies as it
relates to to chinese investment uh
and and other issues as well uh those
complex reviews are just starting
we're starting from a a an approach of
patients as it relates to our
relationship
with china so they're going to review it
john what do you think well
i can just tell you that what jen saki
said is entirely inconsistent with what
the intelligence
shows um the intelligence doesn't say we
should have patience with respect to
china it says that we should act with
respect to china
the the policies that were based on that
intelligence
in the trump administration should be
followed and
you know i increased our spending on
china from an intelligence collection
standpoint
in the intelligence community budget by
20 um
that ought to increase even more going
forward and what i'm hearing are signs
that maybe we'll back off that
you know we want better relations with
china and and you know the path
uh of of appeasement is the road to
nowhere when it comes to china
uh give them an inch they'll take a mile
that's how they became our number one
adversary and that's how they'll
supplant us as a world superpower
what do you think corporate america
needs to understand about this subject
because
right now as we speak there are several
companies that are gearing up
to own and operate their own business in
china
j.p morgan has gotten a license to do so
goldman sachs has gotten a license to do
so
meanwhile we just for the first time in
several months
saw jack ma the founder and builder of
alibaba and the ant
group he made the mistake of saying a
critical
comment about xi jinping's regulatory
environment for financial services
and like that his ant group ipo was
pulled
and he disappeared for two months
this is an important message i think for
corporates who are about to go
to china i mean i would say it's
probably
unheard of that you can actually build a
business and make it
very big and expect to keep it jack ma
learned that lesson
yeah i mean what we've seen is that you
know china sets up the laws to help
china and not to help the businesses
that are there and i i get that it's a
global marketplace and i'm not saying
that you can't do business in china
but what we've seen you know is some of
our own investment banks
basically betting on china and placing
you know
financial success in china over our own
national security
and china knows that that they know that
they can use american businesses
as a means to gain intelligence against
the american
people and our national security posture
so you know again
it's it's um it's something i think that
we need to be more aggressive and learn
from the lessons of the past about how
china will change the law to their
benefit
punish those that speak out against the
government there
and you know china is not our friend um
in business or in any other
enterprise a word on
the cabinet that joe biden is putting
together
and whether or not there are china
appeasers there uh
susan rice uh has been named his head
of domestic policy john your reaction
given all of the work that you did
in terms of exposing crossfire hurricane
and exposing
this effort to take down donald trump
and then a sitting president
donald trump susan rice back in business
at the white house well i'm troubled by
a lot of folks
that that are apparently being
considered and some that have already
been placed
into the uh biden administration because
you as correctly
you correctly point out there maria some
of those individuals were involved in
taking
for instance intelligence that we had
which showed that there was no
russian collusion and turning it into a
fake russian collusion
narrative for political purposes
weaponizing the intelligence that we had
and the intelligence community for
political purposes
and for political gain and to see those
folks that did that
now return to the fold in the in the
biden administration just
leads me to believe that it's going to
happen again that it's all about
accumulating and keeping power and and
making america's national security
subservient to that um we suffered as a
result of those
those actions before and we will again
john before you go your last act as the
director of national intelligence was to
add the u.s
space force uh to the intel community
assessment
why did you do that very interesting
yeah i think uh
time will tell that uh you know that's
going to be probably the greatest
contribution
to the intelligence community and to our
national security posture going forward
you always want to have the high ground
against your adversaries
there's no higher ground than space we
have no near peer
competitor right now china and russia
can't compete with us
in space and we have intelligence
collection streams that we can get
that other countries don't have and uh
and so
you know really important i was uh very
grateful that
president trump and vice president pence
were
supportive and empowered me to get that
done america will be better and safer in
the long run because of it
really interesting john radcliffe it's
great to see you tonight thanks so much
you too thanks maria